how much does the sun really affect the
earth and
do the earth's activities affect the sun
and how many degrees difference is there
between being a big
blue marble and a big orange fireball
these and other burning questions as we
discuss
what if the sun dims down today on what
if discussed
[Music]
welcome to what if discussed i'm richard
garner and i'm peter schweitzen so
richard how much do you think earth
depends on the sun
i think the earth depends a lot on the
sun i'll start with that
uh musically you wouldn't have classics
like here comes the sun
by the beatles uh you wouldn't have
really one of the most underrated steven
spielberg movies and one of my favorites
the empire of the sun with a young
christian bale 12 13 years old i haven't
seen it steals the show
i like christian bale he's very good
obviously a lot of pop culture stuff
of course we wouldn't have my favorite
day of the week sunday for those people
who like to
lounge around and do nothing all day we
would miss sunday
i see where you're going so and uh we
would be absent sunny d
sunny d one of the best beverages
from my childhood commercials capri sun
capri sun yes
uh i was thinking more along scientific
lines oh sure we
tend to do on this show makes sense um
things like
uh oxygen is dependent on the sun
photosynthesis
uh plants produce oxygen as a byproduct
which is essential for human
life and obviously photosynthesis is
essential for plants so plants and
humans
would not exist without the sun fair
enough i will give you those
things as also being important thank you
and of course uh okay lightning round uh
what else do you know about the sun
let's say
i know a bit test me out how many earths
could you fit inside the sun
i'm gonna say well actually i know this
or i think i know this almost remember
it because we did something on this
previously on what if i'm going to say
like 650
000 1 million 1 million earths
inside the sun and of course they would
blow up once they were stuck inside the
sun
because of the heat because the heat is
it exactly 1 million
uh i believe it's probably in the area
code i'm not gonna like don't quote me
on that but yes and as we know the heat
is pretty pretty strong pretty intense
well i'll tell you what the heat is that
because we're doing something in video
and temperature uh color temperature
the color temperature emitted by the sun
is 5600
kelvin which is different from
fahrenheit or degrees but the actual
degrees on the surface of the sun 5027
5027 degrees celsius very hot yeah so
walking might as well be walking on the
sun is another one yes
and i would miss walking on the sun uh
how how long does it take sunlight to
get to the earth
i'm going to say six minutes
eight minutes so it's actually pretty
fast i would have said something like a
day i like i i wouldn't have thought of
that
and obviously we could go on all day
about what peter and i have been
googling
but that's probably not what you tuned
in you probably tuned in for actual
experts so
who's the guest today on the show ah
well let me tell you
the self-professed space gal emily
calandrelli
is an mit engineer turned emmy-nominated
science tv host
she's featured as a correspondent on
bill nye saves the world
and is an executive producer and host of
fox's
exploration outer space she's also been
invited to speak at google
pixar and cern richard that's the
european organization for nuclear
research
emily is also wildly passionate about
space exploration
and believes that we are living in the
most exciting time ever for space travel
so emily thank you for joining us as
someone who knows a little bit about
space and space travel
what are solar cycles and why are they
important
yeah so i think it's really interesting
because when we look at our sun
every day it looks pretty much the same
it really does not appear to change
all that much but the sun is actually
incredibly
active and alive and it goes through
these things
called solar cycles or sunspot cycles
so a sunspot is exactly what it sounds
like it's a spot on the sun that's
a little bit darker a little bit cooler
than the rest of the sun
and we care about sunspots because they
show us
where powerful magnetic fields have
broken through
and emerged from the sun's interior
so sometimes during a solar cycle period
you'll have
a low number of sunspots this is a
solar minimum and then you'll have a
high number of sunspots
this is a solar maximum and then a low
number again so it's kind of like being
on a roller coaster where
it starts at the minimum and then it
goes up and you get to the solar maximum
and then it goes back down
and that process that solar cycle
process takes about
11 years it can be a little bit less it
can be a little bit more but it's about
and so we care about all of this stuff
we care about the areas where
the sun burps up energetic particles and
events like
solar flares and solar mass ejections
because once in a while those things can
come
our way and they can create very like
beautiful not harmful things like the
aurora borealis the northern lights
but sometimes they can actually be a bit
harmful
to humans and to our technology as well
so it sounds like and also space travel
affected by these solar minimums as well
um just like you if we're planning a
trip on earth right now what would we do
we'd we'd
obviously buy our tickets we do a bunch
of stuff but we check the weather right
especially if you're going on a long
drive
similarly nasa is also always looking at
space weather when they're talking about
uh
space exploration and missions what
exactly is space
weather and ultimately how much does it
affect space travel
right um because when you know i
mentioned
auroras like auroras are really really
cool but
just like travel plans um space weather
can actually
be a bit of a nuisance or they can
actually even be dangerous
right so these energetic particles that
are released from the sun
it actually means increased radiation
for humans in space um which is
you know not generally something that
you want so nasa keeps a close eye on
them they check the space
weather to make sure that astronauts
don't have a long exposure
to that they want to track the radiation
that astronauts get in space and they
don't want to pass a certain limit
um and all of this stuff can also be
harmful to
satellites to electronics and satellites
they can disrupt
radio transmissions and even power grids
if they're powerful enough
you know one of the biggest um solar
storms on record is the 1859 carrington
event this was you know
the particles were powerful enough from
the sun to send
electrical charges through telegraph
lines that actually shocked the
operators on the other end and lit
telegraph paper
on fire now this was
before the world was all completely
connected by electrical grid so today
something like that would actually be
much worse but that's all to say that
it's important to know when these things
happen it's important to
check base weather so that people can
take precautions
satellite operators will actually like
reposition their satellites
when they learn about space weather when
they learn that
something is coming their way um you can
take other precautions like
uh temporarily shutting down power grids
and electrical grid for example
um but the best way to protect our
technology and our people is to be able
to better predict
when these things happen i mean we all
know how annoying it is to check the
weather
and for it to say like clear skies that
day
and we're stuck in the rain right
we are constantly trying to get better
weather models and get better data on
our weather here on earth we're doing
the same thing up in space
and so we're doing that with things like
satellites and one of the first
satellites to do this
was launched back in 2007 called the
time history of events and macro scale
interactions during substorms
or it's a mouthful or i think femus or
themis i'm not exactly sure how you
pronounce the acronym
but much better than the actual name
this was a constellation of five
satellites who studied
the earth's magnetosphere how it stores
and releases energy from the sun
and you can think of a mission like that
as our own
space meteorologist gathering data and
helping to understand how solar weather
occurs where it's going where it's going
to what things it's going to affect
and just in general you know predictions
like that from satellite like
we have other ones as well like the
solar dynamics observatory that's doing
a very similar thing
um but yeah satellites like that are
helping to predict space weather so that
we can more efficiently interact with
our technology in space
uh the sun it's it's not necessarily
surprising
but uh it is amazing that even at 93
million miles away or 150
million kilometers away that it has such
an effect
on the entire solar system i mean given
its mass i guess it's not that
surprising but
um talk about living beside another
sleeping beside an elephant like this
but
also at the same time it's possible for
the planets to have an effect on the sun
despite
its size maybe talk about that as well
yeah so this is true i found this
really interesting and to be honest i
didn't know that that was the case until
preparing
for this interview i didn't know this
this is really cool so apparently there
have been some studies
that have shown that planetary tidal
forces on the sun
act like this clock like an outer clock
and they're one of the reasons why the
solar cycle has such a
steady rhythm because one of the big
questions that scientists ask is like
why 11 years why does our sun go through
the cycle
of 11 years that's a bit predictable
right why does that happen
um and from what i've read it's similar
to the gravitational pull that the moon
has
on our earth's tides the planets in our
our solar system have enough coal
to displace some of the plasma on the
uh sun's surface and it's proposed at
least in these studies that
because of the rhythmic nature of our
planet's orbits
that their pool on the sun gives that
sun this type of cycle
um which had previously been you know a
bit of a mystery
it's funny because sometimes like you
hear this type or you read this type of
information
and i find it's interesting like we take
for granted sometimes that we know this
stuff
you know we'll just read it we'll google
it we'll we'll hear somebody talk about
it
and but one of the things you wonder
about or i wonder about especially with
the sun being
a giant fireball is how do we know this
stuff like
how can you accurately measure
all of these different sort of variables
and the vital signs if you will of the
sun what are some of the ways that we're
able to
learn this information about the sun
yeah and i think that's such an
incredible point
that we didn't we weren't born knowing
all of these things
and to this day there are still many
many more mysteries
about the sun and solar weather that
scientists are still
trying to pick apart and pull threads at
and understand
and so they need scientists a new
generation of scientists to be able to
work to answer these questions but the
way that we do it now is mostly with
satellites so we mentioned themis but
the solar dynamics observatory
sdo is a really important one as well
um the solar dynamics observatory is the
satellite that was launched back in 2010
and it watches the sun 24 hours
a day they actually just released this
beautiful video
of a decade of watching the sun where
every single second was one day passing
and it's just beautiful to watch the sun
who
you know we see our star in the sky
every single day and it doesn't really
look like it's changing all that much
but when you take a closer look with
satellites like sdo
you see that it's this beast that is
alive and it is
bubbling and burping and brewing
with plasma and things are exploding
from the surface like it is
like talk about a sleeping elephant
right next to you it is
quite the beast but it's actually very
very beautiful to watch so i would
encourage you to look up that decade um
video but yeah the
satellite studies um all these things
that we're talking about like sunspots
and solar flares and coronal mass
ejections and
all of the things that people with
technology and space care about
and all of us um who care about
astronauts and space care about and
those of us on the ground who rely on
all these technologies care about as
well
so emily our big what if question was
what if the sun
dimmed down how would you go about
tackling that question
yeah i mean that's a big one that it
wouldn't be good
i think that's the main point is that it
wouldn't be good the first thing that i
imagine would happen would be
that photosynthesis um would be harmed
if it dim down enough
photosynthesis and plants just wouldn't
be able to happen
until a lot of the plants would die i
think the trees would last a little bit
longer but
because we have all of these plants
dying out that means just
this whole line of animals would not be
able to survive
and so eventually i think you'd have
some of the larger animals feeding on
some of the smaller animals
but that eventually would not be able to
work either so it wouldn't be great for
life
and i think because humans we rely on
the sun so much
right that's one that's the major reason
we have life here on earth
is that we are we have the right sun
we're the right distance away from our
sun to support liquid water
on our surface and as soon as that
variable
in our equation for life our ingredient
recipe for life
changes then life is gonna have to
change in order to survive
so humans we're gonna have to maybe go
underground
get closer to that geothermal heat maybe
we'll live in
submarines i mean just life would look
totally totally different if our sun
changed
a lot to think about there and a lot of
uh potential
ways for us to die obviously as we are
want to do on what if
emily i want to thank you very much for
joining us and mention to people well
obviously you're very busy you've got
books you're on the speaking surf
circuit you're on tv shows where should
people go to keep up with what you're
doing
so i'm online everywhere as the space
gal and you can find me at
thespacegal.com
perfect thanks a lot thanks so
lots to unpack yeah did anything dawn on
you
as a result of our chat emily ladies and
gentlemen peter smith see what i did
there um
well a lot does right obviously that's
why you talk to the experts because
they're gonna bring you uh you know you
have a certain level of surface
knowledge but then
uh you're gonna be sort of brought on a
journey and emily's emily's first of all
is fantastic at doing that being able to
sort of
dissect complicated astrophysical
information and also
you know communicate in a way that's
easier to understand but
as she also talked about we know very
little still about the sun so yes
if it dim down in the end in the long
term as she said
not good right we're so dependent
photosynthesis
obviously the wildlife us like there's
such a big relationship between the sun
and us that ideally we'd like it to stay
the same
so any massive changes as she used the
word burp
right like in terms of you know like
solar activity whatever but it is kind
of that analogy of the
the elephant that you talked about too
is that you know it is
if it moves then we are affected not to
the degree that we might have thought
but we are
wow so in terms of a solar maximum
um in in terms of uh carrington event
which was something that we touched on
that's what scares me the most that's
what the sun can do to us
to i mean apart from burning us to a
crisp yes
somehow it would be just to like a
coronal mass ejection
that will fry every single piece of
electronics that we have
it last happened back in the days of
telegraph and it
shocked the telegraph operators and set
their telegraph paper on fire
but now in the year 2020
it would fry everything on earth we
would lose all communications all
satellites
all all our power lines like this is
something that could really
end humanity well especially as
dependent as we are that's too much
humanity it's our electronics humanity
would live but just the way we live is
would be completely charged no but if
you could almost go back to a y2k type
scenario right
all those things that were that were you
know
predicted as you know planes falling out
of the sky that type of thing
you do if you start to think about our
dependence on technology
if absolutely every single thing shut
down at once there would be calamity
it's not just
the economy would crash and there'd be
some inconvenience no this
we are so interconnected with technology
that a mass solar event like that solar
flares that people talk about
that does end up being a real problem so
those are some major things with the
solar maximum
but uh uh i was also thinking if the sun
dims down there's some fun things
that could happen too right less
sunburns well less sunburns less glare
on my computer yes i'd be able to read
my phone outside
on the street and it wouldn't be that
big of a deal that does annoy there's
something she also touched on was the
fact that in a solar minimum
we would have less auroras less northern
lights so that's
you know something that's unfortunate
obviously everybody loves a good aurora
borealis
yes i think everybody does and everyone
should strive to see that
yes it's a phenomenon and yeah not to
downplay it the northern lights are
beautiful
yeah and so maybe you'll have to uh
organize your time so that you go every
11 years or something whenever the solar
maximum returns so the maximum activity
is when we see more
auroras and northern lights the minimum
so if we dim down we're in a minimum
we're never going to see that
which again the people at nasa love
because that apparently makes a better
window for space travel
and of course there's more and more
space travel we talk about nasa all the
time but we're not talking about the
elon musks and the
and all these other things i mean it
seems like there's probably going to be
more
space travel space exploration and space
activity
over the next 10 11 years than maybe
we've ever seen since the
the the apollo program yeah yeah
incredible um
we touched on solar weather too so
that's that's what it means getting into
but i mean when you say solar weather to
me it conjures up ideas of like
you know cloudy days partly you know
chance of showers wind so i'm thinking
obviously space is a void yeah but there
are solar winds
yes could i windsurf
in a solar wind could you personally
i can't windsurf to begin with so that's
what i was going to say so could a an
accomplished wind surfer
yes windsurf in a solar wind well uh how
close would they be
to the sun and would they also be in the
void of space
they would also be in the void of space
so they're in a suit they're in some
sort of space suit
obviously like sandra bullock yes yes
yes so
so if she was instead of holding on to
like the canadarm
if she was holding on to uh windsurfer i
think we have our answer right there
because in if you could do a spacewalk
why couldn't you do
a space windsurf yeah right
solved problem solved people
all right i want to say thank you very
much to emily calandreli for joining us
if you want to hear
more with emily and with us click on the
link
below in the description and you can go
to our extended audio version
of the podcast more with emily
calendrelli if you want to know more
about
solar flares solar storms check out our
new show how to survive and
the specific episode how to survive a
solar storm
on behalf of myself and richard garner
i'd like to thank you the viewer for
joining us and we'd like to invite you
to join us next time on
what if discussed